if you're good with it. If you're good with it, we could do the, they're kind of like,
well, not kind of, they're just in credit, like podcasts, I was a big fan of, so I figured I'd
type them up. I typed my own notes to kind of avoid just like a verbatim, you know, kind of
plagiarizing, stealing their ideas situation. And then I went on the New England Journal of
Medicine and looked at this trial regarding oxygenation for pretty much anybody who looks
like they're having an MI. This is dealing with only the ones that aren't hypoxic at baseline,
because, you know, it's very common just to give oxygen, any time having chest pain. And
I had kind of briefly saw something on it that it was bad to do. And so I figured I should go and
look it up. I actually really liked the article. And then I just got, and then I kind of just have
five general questions that I'm sure will branch into more. Sweet. As it goes, but you good with
that flow? Yeah, that's perfect. Sweet. So the first one is kind of the bulk of the trauma. The
second one was pretty self-explanatory. But will you let me know? So I've had COVID, so I didn't
have time to print the notes off like in the binder that I usually have. So will you let me know
if I come off the screen? Because I'm going to pull up the Word document. Yeah, for sure. Okay.
I think it should. Yeah, I think your video will stay up unless I like hit the screen share or one
of us hits the screen share button. Okay, you can still see me. Yeah. All right. So this one was
kind of about the resuscitation of just your classic hemorrhaging patient. The kind of case
that they used was a penetrating gunshot wound, but it was an 18 year old. And the guest speaker
was Richard Dutton, which I guess is a big wig, trauma anesthesiologist in a shock trauma.
Just really good points. I kind of wanted to get your opinion about and everything.
So kind of the clinical case was just the 18 year old male shot in the right chest,
wants upper right quadrant, wants loss of consciousness in the field,
regain consciousness after a liter of crystalloids. Blood pressure is 110 over
70, heart rate 130, tail and lethargic. So he kind of just starts with saying he's going to hang blood
on this guy right away, kind of regardless of how he looks. Throughout it, he really harped on the
fact that he is an 18 year old male, and he can handle deep shock very well in comparison with,
you know, your older patients or even somebody kind of in their 40s or 50s.
He says, so this guy, he said he could lose up to half of his blood and still vital signs wise,
look like he's doing okay. But once this patient crashes with that much blood loss,
it's going to be real sudden, real quick. So he kind of goes over the specifics of kind of how he
would manage it and big wig doctor stuff, kind of how he would let the flow of it happen.
Kind of key thing that I got from this is he talks about induction agents.
He says that the specific agent does not matter, which was new to me because I've always heard
that the accommodate is really hemodynamically stable induction agent along with like ketamine.
He goes on to say that once you're in deep hemorrhagic shock, regardless of if you're
compensating or not, you get these changes in the brain and he did not go into specifics, but
basically stating that hemorrhagic shock itself is rather anesthetic itself. And so saying that
he reduces his dose dramatically in these patients. For example, he was saying that usually he would
give 200 milligrams of propofol so that he would drop it down to 20 in this patient. And he says
that he cannot find at least at the time of this recording, I believe this is from 2013 or maybe
even 2011. So it's been almost or at least over a decade since this came out. But at the time he
was saying there was no research at that time regarding on the subject. And this is something
that he found as a bit of empirical evidence through his practice. I thought that was pretty
interesting, especially in these crashing patients already, because so many of these induction agents,
I would imagine even a thominate and ketamine can drop the patient's pressure even further if
they're already going down. So I kind of wanted to get your thoughts on that first piece about the
reduction of dose in the induction agents. Yes, I think that's a fair generalization that any of
these agents could potentially cause your blood pressure to drop to cause that cardiovascular
collapse. And there's two kind of thought processes about that. One is that some of the agents
it's like a direct effect, like it causes your blood pressure to drop through like vasodilation
or some other effect along those lines. And the other thought is that in some cases your body is
like maintaining its blood pressure through its like endogenous release of catecholamines.
And if you give a large dose of acetative or an analgesic, you're taking that away.
But regardless, whichever mechanism we're working with, like all these agents do have the potential
to cause a drop in blood pressure and potentially lead to cardiac arrest. That said, the specifics
about attenuated doses in RSI, I think since 2013 there's been a fair amount of discussion
about that. That said, I don't know off the top of my head any specific papers that looked into that
about how much to attenuate your dose, like if you're cutting it in half or doing a quarter.
But I know in general that there is more of a movement towards that, particularly in cases
like this where you have like a severe traumatic shock, like hemorrhagic shock state, but also
with elderly patients in general, just across the board. But I'll have to dig and see if there's any
like specific recommendations about like, I don't know when to make that, like maybe like if your
shock index is a certain amount, you attenuate it by half and if it's this much, you can overdose
that. No, like I don't know about the specific guidance. I just know there's a lot of discussion.
But that said, I'm not aware of any like specific guidance on that, but it totally makes sense.
I do think, I wasn't at the conference, but I think, I can't remember the name of the
conference, there's like a big flight medicine conference every year. I wanted to say it was
ASNA, but that's not who it is. But they had a discussion and a talk and like follow up
discussions about this like right before COVID. So it must have been like 2019 or so. And I
remember I had a friend or two reach out to me about that specifically to like, see like, hey,
what are you guys doing? Where you work? I'll see if I can pull up a recording of that, or reach out
to my buddies who mentioned that to me. But yeah, I guess there's a long way of saying that like,
it totally makes sense. And it checks out. I just don't know, like specific guidance.
Yeah. I mean, where I were, we don't have, we don't have specific protocols on that. Like we
don't have specific, like direct guidance on like how much to attenuated dose. But in general, like,
if your dose says you can give up to like X amount of whatever medication, you can always give less,
right? So that, that always falls onto like, under your discretion as a provider.
So yeah, even though it's not explicitly written out, we would have the autonomy to attenuated dose.
Yeah. Well, and I figured if you get to the point of being a flight medic, I mean, you have enough
clinical experience to where your judgment should be, you know, respected. It's not like your new
medic coming off the street. Right. I mean, that's the idea, I guess. Yeah. The other thing that we've
been pushing a lot, like in the industry in general is like before we give any medications
to facilitate intubation, taking the time to resuscitate our patients. So we, we used to run
into the problem where we would just, you know, give full strength medications, these patients
who are already in shock state and we killed them. And then it was like, well, maybe we can give like
smaller doses. And then now I think the, the current process as well, why don't we like
resuscitate first? And I think there's a middle ground, right? Like we like the could resuscitate
and give smaller doses, but we're still in the process of ironing out the details of that.
Yeah. And it seems like it would be a rather difficult thing if for really anybody with
experience, because it seems like medicine has come from getting him intubated very quickly to
now we have a little bit more time with things. Yeah, for sure. I think that in the hospital
setting, this idea of like a delayed sequence intubation has started to catch on. Maybe other
flight programs are doing that as well, or other like ground programs. Not so much out here, but I
think, I think that's where it's headed in the future. We did talk about last time, there are
situations where like you need to, to move quickly. Like in this situation, if this were like, you were
I looking after this particular patient in the field, that's a case where we, we do need to move
quickly. But that's like in the direction of the hospital, not necessarily like move quickly,
like giving him medications that could compromise his like he would never status.
So yeah, I think that's a little bit of a paradigm shift for just EMS in general.
And then particularly in like the flight scene where we're often limited in what we can do in
transport, just because like we work in a tiny little flying tin helicopter.
We have a tendency to want to do these things in a more controlled setting on the ground.
And if we're like looking to resuscitate a patient adequately, it could take a while.
And then we'd like delayed care like, you know, 20, 30, 40 minutes.
And there's, there's argument that like, maybe we just avoid the medications. And you do like,
you just go straight to a cry or you drop a superglottic or, you know,
or use just BLS airway maneuvers. But these are all good questions that hopefully the industry
will figure out one of these days. Yeah, yeah. It would be very nice if they did. Yeah.
Well, it's good to know that they don't have it all figured out. That means we still have things
to look forward to and to learn about. Yes, yes. I like, I like it when new information comes out,
like the research that we're going to talk about a little later. I was very stoked about it.
Why I was stoked about it, I don't much know, you know, but you and I were having a conversation
earlier about the oxygenation just being a very fascinating topic. I just like it, you know,
there's just something about it. That like pulmonary, I don't know, anything really with
the right ventricle and anything where somebody's dying because of the right ventricle.
I like regardless, you know, you probably don't wish people but it is very fascinating.
Yeah, I guess it is a weird, weird thing to have something for but I mean, everyone's got their
thing. Yeah. Well, it's better not liking it at all. Yeah, true. So they kind of move on with
the induction agents and he was even saying he's using propofol but really does not matter and he
was harping on that. So they say they kind of go on with the scenario and the patient is
innovative. And here they say that the blood pressure drops to 50 over 30, just very low.
He Scott Weingart asked the guest speaker, the anesthesiologist, what would you do if you didn't
have blood because I guess the hospital that he comes from, it's just, you know, everything is
squared away very well. There's unlimited amounts of blood for these patients right away. So he asked
for doctors and I would imagine kind of everybody that would run into this situation where you don't
have blood. What would you do? He said it's really a clinical judgment, but he was saying he would
give 250 to 500 through a warmer of just your crystalloid and says he doesn't want to do it,
but he's not just going to watch a patient completely bottom out. Again, he goes back to
stating that while that is a seemingly low number, like this patient will die,
they're not going to die as quickly as, you know, your 80 year old patient would,
but it gets very difficult to get a room of people to kind of stand by while the blood gets
there when you could give them fluids now. So he kind of goes into that and talks about just the
importance of blood that I feel like is kind of very justifiable, kind of beaten to death nowadays
in trauma care, but again, crazy important. So then he kind of goes on and he talks about something
that he does with these patients kind of when they're in surgery. And so he was saying he will
give a combination of blood and a combination of fentanyl, and he will kind of give these 25 to
50 microgram doses to get more vasodilation, basically stating the blood pressure will come
down because of the fentanyl, and then he'll give more blood. And then that'll kind of raise the
pressure, but he was stating he doesn't want these patients at like 110 systolic. He wants to keep
them lower to make the surgeon's job easier. And I know we're kind of getting away from EMS now,
but just the thought process of it was very fascinating. Kind of doing a balancing act with
the fentanyl and with blood and saying once they've hit about 500 micrograms, all these opioid
receptors are just fully taken up. So you won't get a blood pressure drop if you give any more.
He gives a huge slug of it, and then he just manages with blood there. I thought that was
just kind of rather fascinating, and it kind of made me start thinking about the physiology of it.
And it just kind of seemed like a, it seemed correct when he was talking about it, but then
I don't know if my mind started kind of getting twisted in knots, but just seems like why would
you want them to vasodilate? Because even if you're giving more blood, I would imagine
these blood vessels are not bigger, won't it cause it to bleed more?
Then also on that same kind of opposite spectrum, if they are vasoconstricted, eventually they're
going to run out of that catecholamines. So I'm wondering if he was doing it because of that,
because now you're not so much relying on the catecholamines to keep your sympathetic drive up.
And rather he's just returning them to a normal tone, vascular tone, and getting proper fluid in there.
I have to think on this more and either read this or take a listen to it, but
I guess potentially the idea is that if you're in a shock state and your body is trying to maintain
perfusion to things that are vital, so it's going to clamp down at the periphery, things that are
considered non-essential, I guess, and like shun blood to the organs and to the brain. So maybe
the idea that he's referring to is if you're wanting that process a little bit by giving fentanyl,
you maintain perfusion peripherally, so you're avoiding a buildup of
lactic acid and any metabolic byproducts.
And then if you do it too much and the blood pressure goes down, then you get a little bit
of blood. But that I'm not entirely sure about. As a thought experiment, I think it sort of makes
sense, but I have to think on that one a little bit more. Yeah, I guess I'm not familiar with that
strategy of titrating small fentanyl bumps with transfusion, but I also don't work in that setting.
Like I don't work in the OR. So yeah, I have to think on that a little bit more.
But one thing that you mentioned that we kind of skipped over and moved on to the next part was about
the fluids in like things you mentioned, like if you were managing this patient somewhere where
you don't have blood products, like other things you can do, like to avoid cardiovascular collapse
like while you're waiting for blood. So I think that like giving small amounts of fluid is
like it's not ideal, but it's okay. If we are going to get fluids, we for sure want to keep them warm.
So if you're in a facility, you have some kind of warmer. Some transport services do have warmers
that they use like in the field. If you've got nothing, I guess you could like just on the
distal end of your IV tubing, just put all your hot packs there and let it, you know, just like
make a ton of hot packs so that the blood passes through. That works like sort of okay. Like it'll
get like if you're in an outdoor setting in the wintertime, it'll get fluid. Like if you've ever,
I don't know, probably haven't done this, but if you ever had like a bag of IV fluids when it's
cold outside, it's freezing. Like you will be like chilled out instantly and using hot packs will
like get it from freezing cold to like tolerable, but it's still uncomfortable. So I'm not sure
that just using hot packs is like an ideal strategy, but it's better than nothing. So yeah.
And obviously like it probably is a function of like how many you have and how well you like,
you know, the more surface area of that hot pack on the tubing, like the more it'll get warm. So yeah,
I guess if you, if you didn't have blood, things you could do is like, just make sure you can do
whatever you can to keep your patient warm. So like warm your IV fluids, if you're giving out fluids,
put blankets on them, turn the heat up in the back of the truck or in the trauma bay or the OR,
wherever you are. And then in this situation, the patient is probably intubated because we already
talked about like our RSI medications. So one of the things in that, like we used to refer to it
as a trauma triad of death. Now we're tending to call it like the lethal diamond. Yeah. One of the
components there would be acidosis. So we can potentially like mitigate that a little bit by
ventilating our patient to a goal that's higher than normal. As far as like how to measure that
goal, like what specific quantitative value we're looking for that, that data really hasn't
like flushed out yet. But basically the simple way to do this is whatever your baseline entitled CO2
is, you don't want it to go higher. You want to keep it there or lower. It's totally okay to like
have a patient who's like, we're ventilating them until their end title is like down into the 20s.
The caveat there is that if they're like in a low perfusion state, their end titles also
can be low. So it's kind of hard to measure. But basically like if you had them on a ventilator,
you can just aim for a minute volume or minute ventilation goal that's like higher than what's
normal. So we would say that this might be a little like too far into the weeds on this,
but we'd say like for the average patients, our normal minute volume goal is a hundred
mils per kilo per minute. And then somewhere in the area of like twice that is probably okay
for someone who's markedly acidotic or who wants to prevent them from getting markedly acidotic.
Now that double number is like, I don't know of any data that like fully supports that.
So anywhere like between the normal hundred and like the double of 200, like somewhere in that
range is better than nothing. But basically we don't want them to get more acidotic. We use the
ventilator as a machine to like prevent that from happening and ideally correct it. But like in the
acute setting, like we're not going to fix it fast, but just prevent it from getting worse.
So yeah. And the last thing, like if we don't have blood,
most places had access to TXA now. So that's another thing we can do.
Yeah. So yeah, I mean, standard bleeding control, obviously. And then TXA, keep the patient warm
and do whatever you can to prevent acidosis. The calcium part of this diamond is mostly
discussed in the context of giving blood products. There may be an argument and I don't
actually know enough about this particular point of giving calcium in general, just to facilitate
the clotting cascade. And we talked about last time about increasing like cardiac function,
cardiac contractility, by giving calcium with the calcium is low.
I don't know what the, like if you were just to take like a random sample of calcium levels
of people coming into the hospital in like traumatic injury, like what percentage of them
are low of normal, but like maybe we give calcium even in the absence of getting blood products,
just to help with that part of it. That I don't know about. I'll see if I can find something to
either support or refute that. But yeah, those are all the things you could do like while we're
waiting for blood to show up, I guess. Yeah. And it sounds like a lot of that would be
good to do because how many ambulance services realistically have blood. Sounds like that would
be really good stuff to do on the way to the hospital. Yeah. And all of those things are
things we can do in the ambulance. Yep. And hopefully we'll see more ground EMS programs
carrying blood in the future. But yeah, yeah. We'll get there someday.
It's funny that you brought up calcium because the second thing I typed up,
the second podcast is exactly over that the hypocalcemia with hemorrhage. And you covered.
And these are both, these are both M Crip podcasts. Yes, sir. What are the,
what are the numbers? I can come up after. I can send it to me later. That's fine. Yeah. So I went
to the archives. I'll pull them up for you. But yeah, the Richard Dutton one is a M Crip podcast,
30 minutes. And then this one that we're about to discuss was a 20 minute one.
So just like you were saying, they added the hypocalcemia to the, what used to be the deadly
triad making it a diamond now. So they were talking about blood products, just in general,
and saying how to situate in them to keep the blood from clotting in and of itself,
just when it's in the bag. But saying that the citrate will result in a lack of calcium,
it will drop the calcium. They're already having a hypocalcemia problem from directly bleeding it
out on whatever surface. So they were saying they like to give calcium. Now I don't really
remember where these two people work. But one of them was like a special forces medic. And now he
was in med school. And then I believe another one was a doctor actively. So one of the guys has
really good information on kind of how the military does things, how the military is working
to do things. And it sounds like he was on one of the research teams in the military regarding
hemorrhagic shock exclusively. So he has a lot of good tidbits in there. But the protocol that he
was saying he used or rather maybe he uses at the time of the recording, he was saying he just
pushes one gram of the calcium chloride during the first unit of blood. And then from that point,
for every two units, he was given another gram. He says some people do four units, given another gram.
But he really just goes into good detail just basically talking about how this calcium is
crucial for the clotting cascade. Scott, it's kind of funny that you brought up the fact that you
can't think of any study that has been, you know, what is the calcium level of these hemorrhagic
shock patients, because he was very stoked about this topic, saying that for years, he's
kind of done like a little project of his own, he'll go back on these patients that he has and
kind of track their calcium and saying that it was very, very low. But obviously, he can't just go
around saying, Oh, I pulled these labs and try to produce research. So he was pretty stoked about
that. It was overall, seems pretty basic, just the information that they were giving out, just
making sure we're giving calcium, it really does make a difference. It can make a difference quickly.
I liked it a lot. I did not know they were saying hypercline is a common response to trauma.
I did not know that I know if you have a crush injury, the breakdown of that muscle can lead to
hypercline, but I did not know that in and of itself, just bleeding itself causes hypercline.
And I wonder if it's because you're bleeding calcium out, and don't the two kind of antagonize
one another? That I, this is another thing I'm not entirely sure about, but I think maybe
two mechanisms. One would be that in an acidotic state, in general, your body,
like your cells in your body become a little more permeable and potassium leaks out.
So same thing in like a diabetic ketoacidosis, where we're about hyperkalemia.
So that's the one mechanism where, like, just because you're in like a low-provision shock state,
you're locally getting acidotic at those cells and they leak potassium in. The other one we did
just from tissue damage, like from when a tan, like Lou's not able to talk right now, when a cell
is damaged and it breaks, when lysis occurs, you lose potassium like directly there. So it can be
either one of those mechanisms, and likely it's some combination both, but I'll have to look into
that specifically to be sure. Or it could be something else that I'm not considering.
Yeah, I mean, it sounds right to me, man. If it sounds good to two people, it's gotta be right.
See, this is problematic. This is where problems come from.
Yeah, the entirety of Facebook, there's like 20,000 people in groups that are...
Yeah, because you could just look for someone who agrees with you.
Yes, yeah. You know, I wonder if people think that, because nowadays you hear especially a
bit of the older generation, maybe 40s and 50s, no disrespect to them, but you kind of hear them use
Facebook as like a legit argument, you know? And I wonder if they, obviously they know, but I wonder
if they give any thoughts of the fact that, you know, there's almost 400 million people in America
alone, you're bound to have a political subject, or there's tens of thousands of people all agreeing
on the same topic. Yeah, that is problematic. Although I don't have any experience with
Facebook, so I can't, yeah. I manage to steer clear of that one. I despise social media,
not because like, I don't follow people that I don't like seeing their opinion, right? But
there's a lot of interesting things that are both kind of informative and just absolute nonsense,
and I find myself wasting large amounts of time.
All right, so this... So the trial I looked into, before we move on, are we good with trauma?
Yeah, I think so. I don't know if you had any specific questions about the calcium,
but it seems like you, hey, you got your basic basis covered there. I think I actually have
listened to that MCRA episode, so I'll put a link up here, and also like the research that the guys
did, I think it was, I remember who it was, I should probably know this off the top of my head,
but the papers they did through the military about like investigating this idea of giving potassium
with transfusions in the field. So I'll pull up links and send them to you.
Oh yeah, yeah. I'm building a small collection on the things you see.
So just to kind of summarize with the trauma, just keep them warm. Try not to give them fluids
if you don't have to. Give your TXA, give your calcium, get up and get gone for the field
ambulances. Kind of the same suite. With that, I think that is good on the, you know what, let me
ask about it now because I have it written down, but really just kind of fits in. So with your
head traumas, I know that the overall CO2 plays a big, big factor, and I believe if the CO2 is high,
they get the increased intercranial pressure, correct? And if it's really low, they get the
cerebral vasoconstriction? Yeah. Okay. So if they're,
yeah, if they're hypoventilating and their end tidal gets high,
that can cause an increase in ICP. But then again, if we like hyperventilate them super low,
and that's also problematic. So yeah, we generally aim for a goal just like low of normal. If we're
like ventilating somebody, our normal goal would be like 35 to 45, and we'll like do it on the lower
end of normal or like maybe down to 30, 30 to 35. Okay. And my second question on that. So,
and I forget where I read this, and I don't know how common this is in head injury patients. I've
maybe had three pretty bad blunt trauma head patients. But just the, is there, or have you
been in a situation where you can't, with a normal respiratory rate, you can't keep that end tidal
where you want it, and it just seems like it's jacking through the roof? And if so, what do you
think about brief hyperventilation to do that? Or I would imagine that would cause problems in
and of itself, with just stacking all that pressure in the chest. Yeah, I guess I've never ran into
that issue. Like we sometimes have a tough time maintaining like our ventilation, like with our
end tidal being super high if we had like some kind of like chronic lung disease. But generally,
like aside from that subpopulation, like it's pretty easy to like ventilate people down, like to
hyperventilate or to ventilate more than whatever our normal metabolic volume would be to get their
end tidal to go down. We sometimes, we more often run into the opposite problem where a patient is
breathing way faster than we would want, which is a little bit safer for us, like as far as managing
vent. So we more commonly see a situation where the patient is like breathing too much and our
end tidal is low of goal. We don't often see it outside of that subpopulation with chronic lung
disease where we have a high end tidal CO2 that we can't bring down. Well, yeah, I guess I've never
been in that particular situation. Yeah, it seems like kind of impossible, but like unlikely to
happen. Yeah, yeah. Especially once you're like managing, like if you've intubated them and you're
managing the airway manually, then like it would be a different case. Let's say if you
get a patient spontaneously breathing and you had like a side stream can you long them and you're
monitoring it that way. But then if you saw like in that situation, if you saw that they like weren't
moving enough volume, like their minute volume was low and that was indicated by a high end tidal
CO2, that would be an indication that maybe you need to more aggressively manage airway, like start
PD and ventilations or work towards RSI or something like that. It seems like RSI really,
once you kind of give that paralytic, it seems like it removes a lot of these
kind of situations at hand because now you just have full control. Yeah, I mean, it seems like the
ideal situation because you just take everything away and then like you're in charge. Yeah. But
then it's all on you to like know what to do. So it's potentially problematic as well.
Were you nervous the first time you RSI'd somebody? Oh yeah, for sure. Yeah. Yeah. They don't give us
RSI where I work and I'm not, I would like to RSI people, but yeah, I would imagine it would be a
very nerve wracking thing. Yeah. I mean, it's definitely an interesting skill to go from like
work on an ambulance where you don't have access to that. And then like it being like in your
scope and you could potentially do it on any shift. Yeah. Like, I mean, I still get like,
you know, when I do have the RSI, like I'm not like a superstar. It's not like I don't get nervous
and like my heart doesn't go faster. But we have like systems for like how to manage that effectively.
Like I religiously use a checklist. Like I, you know, whenever I'm, not every time, but like often
when I'm at a base that has like airway heads sitting around, like I'll just get out and play
with it. Like I'll practice my bougie techniques and just like do a couple like manipulations
there. Like, I don't know. Like I think that if I didn't do those things, I would probably feel
a lot more nervous whenever it came up. But yeah, it was like one of the things that like, I know
that it's like, it could potentially be stressful. So like, whatever I can do ahead of time to
mitigate that then. Yeah. That has helped a lot for me. And some people just wing it and they're
just good at it. And they just like, like, yeah, there are like many, many medics out there who do
RSI and like never use a checklist, don't really do things the same way every time. And like they've
never failed. So, but like, I don't think we should bank on that. Right. Like, I think we should have
systems for those kinds of things. Yes, very much. Yeah.
Sweet. That cuts that out. And that is the last of my trauma. Everything else is a medical.
Yes. All right. Let's hear it.
You want to finish the questions now or you want to move on to the MI trial? It is your choice.
Let's talk about the, you said you had some oxygen stuff to talk about.
Yeah. That's what this trial is. All right. Yeah, let's do that. So essentially this group went
and used, they went and gathered about 6600 patients over the course of, I think four or
five years. And this is in Sweden. They had somewhat strict criteria. You had to be sat
in at 90% on room air. You had to be 30 years or older. You had to have had symptoms, your classic
kind of cardinal symptoms, chest pain or short of breath, less than six hours. You had to have either
elevated components or EKGs. And that was pretty much it. So what they wanted to find out was,
does oxygen actually help in your patient that is not hypoxic on room air with all these,
with basically heart attacks is what they wanted. And they ended up getting 75% of their patients
ended up with the final diagnosis of either non-stimmy or stimmy. So, so with this, their methods
they used six liters per minute for anywhere in between six to 12 hours. The median ended up
being 11 and a half hours that you did it through an open face mask. And I don't know if that is
like a non-re breather. I don't know if that's more of a Swedish thing or all we have is non-re breathers.
I guess the open face mask we have is we'll do like NED treatments through it.
But yeah, it's kind of like a, the non-re breather mask, but no reservoir and just oxygen into the
mask. And then it's not, it doesn't have like the flaps on it. It's got holes in it. So it's
kind of like doing blow by that for grown up, essentially.
So they took their two control groups. One was just the ambient air and the other one was receiving
the oxygen through the, again, the six liters, six to 12 hours. So they kind of looked at three
things. What was their final oxygen after the, what was their final oxygen on room air at the
end of treatment? What was the one year mortality? What was the readmission on these two groups?
So with the final oxygen or saturation, 99% was the oxygen group, 97% was the ambient air group.
For the one year mortality, it was a 0.1 difference. 5% for the oxygen group, 5.1% for the
ambient group. Readmission rates within one year, the oxygen group was at 3.8% and the
ambient air group was at 3.3%. The mortality was any cause of that though. There was no
repeat heart attack. It was just basic one year mortality. They kind of go on to
discuss a little bit further how they did it. Again, they included like the final diagnosis of
it. They went into more detail on the inclusion criteria. The really only real exclusion criteria
was if you went into cardiac arrest with EMS or you arrested at the hospital because they're going
to put you way past six liters per minute, just managing your airway. They, I liked it a lot
because they're evidence with the 6,600 patients. And from what I could find, this was the largest
trial at the time with the 6,600 people, 3,300 in each group, just showing that there is no
difference in the outcomes of at least their patients who were not hypoxic. Now granted,
he talked about a lower mortality rate with theirs being 5%. I think the average in Sweden
was 14%. They explained that by just saying a large chunk of the people that die will be hypoxic
so they can't be included in the criteria. So this was solely on if you're oxygenating enough
on your own. He did mention two other trials and I have not looked into these trials so I don't
want to go and speak ill of them at all. He talks about one is the AVOID trial. It's an acronym just
like this detox trial is. They reported larger infarcts and now this was only STEMI patients and
theirs that were receiving the O2. And then the Cochrane report and the 2016 update was saying
that there's no evidence of it. They were talking as if this is kind of something that is seen
with these new studies coming out and saying, but again, they did not show, this study did not
show any harm in it. So I was kind of wondering your thoughts on that. I personally, if I have a
MI patient, if they're not short of breath and they're sitting, sagging fine, I don't put them
on oxygen. I went and found this because I've got crew like crew members and they're great at what
they do, but that's what they know, you know, and will show up to a house and you know, you get busy
and sometimes the fire truck gets there before you, maybe you're racing back from a hospital.
And I've had a situation where patient was fine, everything was fine, but it looked like a non-STEMI
and they had them on four liters. I turned it off and I find myself often having to
unplug. It just seems like an EMS, it's very common to just kind of blanket oxygen people.
Yeah. I mean, that was how I was taught when I first, like I guess I did, I'm sorry, to my CPR
class and first responder stuff through a fire department. And that was the rules. Like everyone
gets oxygen. So it makes it look like you're caring for the patient and probably doesn't hurt.
Right. And to be honest, like I think that like in the last couple of years, there's a lot of like,
a lot of discussion about the damage that oxygen can cause. But I think in most situations,
particularly in EMS, like it probably doesn't impact outcomes, like as, as explained in this paper.
So like, if you're, if you're in a hospital setting and there's, you know, like you're leaving somebody
on the six liters for days and days and days, like it's probably different, but for like, you know,
in the study, 11 hours, like, you know, are setting like less than an hour, probably doesn't
matter. So like in your situation, like you have somebody with a playing of chest pain and somebody
else puts up an oxygen, it's probably not worth like ruffling feathers to be like, Oh, let's take
that off. Right. It's probably worth it. Just leave it. And then when you get in the truck and like
you're by yourself and you can like turn it off, it's not going to hurt anything acutely. So yeah,
I guess that's kind of, that's kind of where, how I feel about that. I think that this,
yeah, this, this comes up a lot. Like I actually just recently saw a post at the look and see who
it was. But there's this like phenomenon in the lungs called hypoxic pulmonary vasoconstriction.
Yes. So basically the way it works is if you're, if your blood vessels in your lungs
get hypoxic, they constrict down, which is the opposite of what happens like peripherally in your
body. So like in my arm, if it's hypoxic, if my arm is hypoxic, those blood vessels dilate to get
more oxygen there. Right. But in the lungs, there's like a, an all, an opposite reaction. And the idea
there is that it prevents like blood flow from being wasted. So if I have a region of the lung
that's like not getting oxygen, I shunt blood away from that region so that I can like keep the
blood going to place the target oxygen. Right. On the flip side, there was a post recently that
somebody put up about the idea that if you give too much oxygen to somebody, this mechanism could
cause like worse outcomes. So if you, I'm trying to like think through the sequence here. So if
you had somebody who like had poor perfusion to a part and then the Avioli, like the Avioli were
not, didn't have a lot of oxygen in them and their perfusion was poor, but you give more oxygen and
then it causes vasodilation. You could like cause a shunt where you're like wasting blood flow,
which talking to the steps of that, that like sort of makes sense, but I don't think that actually
happens to a degree that would have a clinical impact in real life because that doesn't always
happen super fast. It's not like an automatic one and off thing. That's something that like I,
I reached out to whoever was it, like posted me like, Hey, like, let's, let's talk about this.
Like, I'm curious to know like where this came from. I haven't heard back from them yet, but
I would be interested to explore that idea a little bit more. Basically like in the, in the
greater context of like, I think that like it's worth limiting oxygen to when it's actually
indicated. But I do think that there was like a movement to finding like everything wrong with
oxygen that is potentially problematic. Cause then you have like cases where people do need
oxygen and don't get it. Whereas like the damage caused by giving oxygen is, is quite limited,
like potentially even like negligible in the EMS setting. I say potentially cause like, I, I think
there probably are cases where like we probably shouldn't give it and it could cause damage,
but like, I don't think that those situations are that frequent in, in the EMS or even in the
critical care transport setting. I think it's more of like a long-term situation.
And I like, I like that you stated that it is that long-term cause the original reason that I
wanted to look into this was I just wanted to be sure that there wasn't something out there,
you know, saying we're just doing devastating effects to people and oh, I found this out,
you know, like, oh, I'm kind of incompetent. Yeah. I don't know if this is where the,
the whole idea started, but they're back in the day with like babies, we used to like leave them
on high flow oxygen for a long period of time, you know, for like days or weeks, maybe. Oh, wow.
And come to find out that that can cause like, I don't know, specifically it caused problems with
the eyes, like the eyes don't develop quite like they should. So you had like kids growing up with
like poor vision and they, they kind of like worked backwards and figured out that like,
oh, maybe we shouldn't be giving these babies auction for a long period of time. And the
culprit there is these like free radicals, right? Which I honestly like would have to like consult
the textbook to figure out how the specific details that you said that man, because I was like, I
don't know what the hell a free radical is. Yeah. But that, that narrative, like oxygen is bad
because it like hurt these babies eyes has like carried over and kind of like snowballed into this
effect where like everyone's like anti-oxygen other than the guys who like and gals who like
just grew up in like the first responder community where we put oxygen on anyone.
Right. So there's like that mentality still exist. And then there's like a new mentality where like,
oh, oxygen is bad. Don't give it to anyone. But like we, we live in the middle and in our setting
where we're like acutely managing patients, like it probably doesn't matter that much.
But yeah, I guess in summary, like if your patient's hypoxic based on like a pulse ox,
give them oxygen. If they're not like, we don't need to, but if somebody did and you want to
save face and like not rough feathers, it's probably okay. And then if it's like appropriate
for you to do it when they're like out of eyeshadow or whatever, then you can, then you can make your
own decision. But I don't know if it's worth like putting your foot down on a scene like that to be
like, oh, like oxygen dangerous. Yes. I've never so far, I've never had to do anything of putting
my foot down. And I really hope I don't because I work with the same people every day, you know,
it's the same ship, same crew. And they're all very, I mean, they basically raised me, you know,
right? So I definitely don't want to go and be pissing them off. We talking trash to where
everybody's pissed off once a ship anyway, you know, I don't need something serious to get them
upset. Yeah. And this is, this like brings up something that's like sort of related, like,
if there's ever like in that situation where you're like a relatively new guy in this,
in this setting where people are doing things that like don't align with practice,
but like the culture allows for like joking and hazing and that kind of thing.
Like you can always like address that in a joking way. Like, I don't know, like make a joke about
like, Oh, I didn't know what to do. So I put oxygen on them. Right? Like you can, you can,
address it in a way that's not like confrontational. You know, like I make the joke with like some of
the people I work with who like are resistant to using bougies. Like if I set you up for an airway,
I'm just going to take the style it out and throw in the trash and like such a bougie. Right? Like,
you don't have to like, you know, you like do it like, yeah, yeah, lighthearted. Yeah. So I don't
know. It's like just a potential thought I had there. I like it, man. As far as the, those are
kind of my three things that I wanted to discuss. I do feel much better than, and again, this trials
has a median duration of 11 and a half hours of oxygen delivery. So what are the odds that
the, even an hour transport, if I'm going from the sticks to like a city, city hospital,
that's an app. Yeah. It's really doing any harm whatsoever. Right. Yeah. I thought of another
example that sort of explains this. There's this concept of like absorption atelectasis. You heard
of that. It's like the idea is that in your Avioli, you have oxygen and mostly nitrogen. So like at
baseline, you have like 21% oxygen and whatever the rest is like 79%, 78%, then that's 1% of random
stuff. So like, if this is your Avioli and you have like just 21%, like getting absorbed into
the bloodstream, like it like shrinks a little bit, right? But if you like do a oxygen washout
and fill the whole thing up with oxygen, when the oxygen like goes into the bloodstream, like that
Avioli collapses. This is the theory. So the argument is that like, don't give, don't do like
a nitrogen washout. Like don't just give a hundred percent oxygen to all that nitrogen is gone.
Because if your patient's super hypoxic, then like you're going to collapse their Avioli.
But that said, like I don't, this is another one of those cases where like, I don't think
that the data fully supports that. This is like kind of up in the air.
Yeah. It's not just that the Avioli is being held open by like forces, like pushing it open,
like air in a balloon. Like there are like external things like around the surface of the
Avioli holding it open. Like, you know, like you have surface tension of fluid on the outside of
it. It's like helping it maintain its state. Like, is that the surfactant? Yeah. So yeah,
I'm not, I'm not convinced that that actually happens, but I don't know. It's just like another
interesting thought about the, the, I don't know, the oxygen haters out there. It's fun, man.
And just the one last piece on that. So like your surfactant kind of keeps it from collapsing,
correct? There's multiple things to it, but that's one of the bigger biological factors of it. Yeah.
And then your elastin helps it actually like the Avioli exhale in and of themselves, right?
Because your COPD or emphysema itself, it traps air because it destroys that elastin.
Yeah. So the elastin is again, something I should probably reference in the textbook before I talk
about, but it, fire all right. The elastin is what's like pulling it back, like it's causing it to
recoil versus the surfactant is like holding it open. So yeah, that, that I guess makes sense.
Like if the elastin is broken down, then you get like that hyperinflation. Yeah. So that's why like
you have these external forces that are like managing to some effect the shape of that
heavy. Like it's not just the pressure of the air inside of it. That's why I don't, I'm not,
I'm not a hundred percent convinced that like the absorption out of like this thing is valid,
but it likely is somewhere in the middle, right? Like maybe it has like some effect.
I mean, I think that's probably the case for like most of these like niche details we're trying to
work out. Like oxygen isn't bad, but it, you know, it does have like some therapeutic value.
We shouldn't never give it and we shouldn't always give it like, yeah,
sometimes everything in moderation. I like the things, you know, just do the things because
they've always been done. It's just an absolutely terrible reason to be doing anything medical.
Yeah, that's true. So if you're good with it, I just got a couple more questions for you.
Yeah. So I know we talked about, we've been talking about ketamine a lot. I feel like you've
told me this, but usually I'm typing notes. So I'm not doing that this time. Cause I feel like
sometimes I miss one or two things with the, let's say you're going to give an axial
pulse, right? I know we talked about the 0.25 milligrams per kilo over 10 for pain.
If you're going to give this for, let's just say you've innovated somebody or just any
procedural sedation is what we have for what, if you're pushing one milligram per kilo, I know
you're not going to slam it, right? Cause it seems like a bad idea, but what timing kind of, and I
know nobody's actually sitting there with a stopwatch on their iPhone, you know, looking at it, none of
us do, but would you do it kind of slower than you would like other medications or. Yeah. I mean, I,
I don't often like give medications where I just like slam it. A lot of times we just have like an
IV bag hanging cause it like makes it easier to get to like, you can put your medications in a port.
So like, if I were going to give a bolus dose Academy, like if I just have like a couple of
trips going, like I would just put it in the line and you can slam it in the line. Like it's not
like it's fair. I mean, get all the way in the patient right away and just let it drip in.
That's how I do like most of my pushes. If I am getting it as a push, like I just give it,
I don't know, slowly, like, you know, like I grabbed the syringe, I hook it up and then,
okay. I don't know. Like, so, and then I do the same thing with that with a flush, you know,
just slowly behind it. Yeah. I mean, I'm not, yeah. I mean, I think like if you,
if you're giving a big dose of ketamine and your patient's like alert, like there is, you know,
you could potentially cause like transient, like, um, you know, hypoventilation or something like
that. But like in our cases when we're giving big doses, like the patient's already intubated.
So it's not really so much of a worry for us. Um, yeah, I think it's more of an issue, like
in the like procedural sedation side of things, like let's say you're in the ER and you like
broke your arm and you're trying to set it. Um, in that situation, like working in the ER setting,
I've been in ER in a couple of years, but like, then I would be a little more diligent about like
giving it super slowly. Um, especially like when my patients, like it's easier to do that kind of
stuff. Like you're talking to a patient and you're like, all right, I'm going to give this,
we're going to give it over like 30 seconds and like you're just sitting there with them hanging
out. Like it's easier. What it was like for us, like, yeah, it's, it's not so, it's not so relevant
in our setting. Yes. Yeah. Yes. I like it. I gave ketamine for the first time right before I got
COVID. We ran a code and the lady legit like started like, as soon as I innovated their
entire, she had to have gone from a PEA. That's not a real PEA to now she's contracting enough for
pulse, but she was maybe we had like maybe five minutes left, you know, too much time for you to
just be flailing your hands kind of bad. It wasn't like, you know, it wasn't coordinated by any means.
It's just kind of flailing stops and flailing. So I gave the one and I, I just pushed it like a normal.
So I'm glad that you said that. Yeah. Yeah. And in that case, like if your patients didn't debate it,
like, I mean, we don't necessarily, like we never really need to like actually like slam medications
other than adenosine. But like, as long as you're giving it like, somewhat reasonably.
Yeah. That's the official, the official, somewhat reasonably. Yeah. I like it. Did I have this patient,
you know, just your frequent flyers, like call you at two in the morning type. And I took him to a,
just the normal ER wasn't like our local one or anything, but it was in the city. And I had a
nurse that was like, I told her, you know, I'll always say in this hurts. He's in pain.
I didn't give him any NARCS. And she's like, I'm a slam vinegar.
Nurse Bratzman.
Let me get away from you for my license is going as well.
So Rebel, I saw Rebel EM, it was an Instagram post and I, he was talking about glucagon for
the airway, the smooth muscle reaction. And he was just saying it really doesn't work was kind
of his thing. And I'm sure I'm strongly summarizing what he said. But then so I asked him about
magnesium, because I had also heard about magnesium, especially from some like older medics.
And one of them in particular, I love the guy to death. I mean, I respect him like his family, but
he told me a story about he gave a patient magnesium for like relaxing the airway. And
just an old man, you know, choking on a steak. And he said that by the time he got there at work,
now granted, who's really gonna know if magnesium was it or if he just actually passed it down
finally. But I just thought it was interesting how he was kind of, and I would assume the guy
posting for Rebel EM is rather bright. So you agree none of them really worked that well for
smooth muscle in the airway. Yeah, I don't know of anyone personally who's ever like
had any success, or even ever tried like giving glucagon, that used to be something we would teach
in medic programs. If you have someone choking to get glucagon, but a lot of places don't even
carry glucagon anymore, because it's kind of expensive and like hard to get. Yeah.
Yeah. And like you, if you have someone choking, you're not going to take the time to like
reconstitute a medication to get there. Like you're going to be, you're going to be doing other
things. And then like with the magnesium, like we generally don't want to get that fast. So you're
not going to like set it up to infuse over 10 minutes and like hope they're like still
10 minutes later. Like that seems a little problematic. Very much so. So yeah, like I don't,
I guess I haven't put a lot of thought into that one in a very long time, but I wouldn't
mess with like giving drugs to try and get like smooth muscle relaxation, somebody choking.
Yeah. It just never really seemed like a good idea. You know, like,
especially with bag, pretty much every use of it is slow. Yeah. You answered the hyperventilation
one with that. And then, you know how they say, and I guess it's more than just they say, but with
pediatric cardiac arrest, it's the airway and the respirations are the problem, a huge majority of
the time. Right. Would you, you know, would you tube them right away? Not so let's, we're not
skipping any of the vital stuff that we do, right? Like let's say they're in full cardiac arrest,
you know, you're still putting them on the monitor. You're still doing compressions. You're still
getting a line or an IO, but would you make it a point to tube them a lot quicker just to, because
not necessarily. Like I think still I make is really depends on like how many hands you have on
scene. Like once you have free hands to manage the airway, like that's the appropriate time.
Like if it's just like you and your partner, like it's probably not going to be the appropriate time
until someone else shows up. But like, if you're rolling up with like six humans, like you might
as well be sooner, but like, I don't think I would skip other things to prioritize that
because you are ventilating the patient, you know, with a medium, just focus on like doing
like good ventilations, like actually like getting that airway open and make sure the seal
and then laying the patient like per your resuscitation protocol. So yeah, I don't,
yeah, I wouldn't switch everything up to try and do that sooner.
Sweet. I would imagine that is a stressful enough situation to be
purposely putting yourself at it, like the groove that you have for code.
Yeah, and I think that that's, that's like a really important point is that I've noticed like
when I've like made mistakes, it's because I like deviate from what is normal, either because like,
I don't know, like something catches me off guard and like I go down a rabbit hole, or like I just
was lazy and not prepared. A very good example of this is like, I've always been like super
religious about like when I go on scene, like always taking my stuff in with me, and like in
my bags, you know, like it probably drives my partners crazy at work sometimes. They're like,
no, this is just like a, basically a BLS transfer, like, we're still going to carry everything in
because what if something happens? Like what if? But I ran a call once for like somebody having a
seizure. And like I walked in the room, like in the patient's home, there was somebody at the
door waving me in. And I walked in without waiting for my partner, like we'd always like
carry stuff in together. And the guy was no longer having a seizure, but he was up and like ready to
fight. And like, like a sprawny white dude, like working on the truck in Pittsburgh, like almost
got my ass kicked because like, I was like, excited about this seizure call, like, oh,
maybe I could do something cool. And I left my partner outside. And like, it was me against this
like, dude, who was probably gonna win that fight. So yeah, same thing with like, like airway
management stuff. Like now I've kind of kicked the idea of like, being too cool for checklist.
So I don't really have to worry about that. But like, that is a very common problem, I think,
or used to be a problem for me. And like, generally any messes that we like,
have a sense of confidence in our ability to do those things, we think we don't need help.
Same thing applies to the bougie. Like, nobody wants to use the bougie because they already know
how to intubate. But yeah, anytime you deviate from your team, like you introduce the possibility
of like, more problems. So if you're used to running a code specifically with adults,
when you have a kid, do the exact same thing, just change your doses, and your ratio, I guess,
yes, is the point I was trying to make, like, don't, don't think you need to switch it up.
Yeah, I like it. Because I'll be damned if I run a bad code, and it's a kid, you know, like,
it is, I feel like if I work in the business long enough, just statistically, it's going to happen,
you know, but let's do everything kind of like what you were saying earlier about practicing
your innovations and the things that are high intensity, but low frequency, you know,
and just doing everything you can to be prepared for it.
Yeah. Yeah, another another thing, like, along those lines is I don't know if you've
checked out the podcast, but I'll send you a link. I did an episode, I only have like a few
podcasts out, like I don't do it that often. But I recorded an episode like a year or so ago with a
buddy of mine. And he had just started a job with a new flight program. And he was trying to like
learn his new protocols. So he basically like recorded himself, like speaking through his
algorithms. And he just did it from memory until he like had them all memorized. And then like,
now he has them recorded on his phone. So like when he's driving to work, whatever you can like,
listen to them, just crush up. And I did the same thing for like my RSI procedure where I work. So
which is like a step by step of like how ideally I would want that scenario to go and to have it
as a recording on my phone. So like, like I work like all my shifts in like two week chunks,
I work for two weeks and have two weeks off. So when I'm going back to work, like I have this
like process for like getting back in the mood for going to work. And that's one of my things,
like, you know, when I'm like commuting to wherever I'm going, I like listen to this once or twice,
like, okay, like, cool, like, yeah, just like a way to like, yeah, there's a lot of like data out
there about like visualizing performance as a way to practice when you like don't have access
to the things. But I find it pretty tough to like, just like close my eyes and think about it like
that doesn't work for me. But like having a having an audio script playing in my mind, like,
is enough of an anchor to like visualizing that that it works for me. I don't have it works for
everyone. But I'll send you a link. It's worth like thinking about like, if there's, you know,
like, if you wanted to like do something like that for working in pediatric code.
I think that's like a reasonable thing to practice.
Yeah, absolutely. Well, I had talked to a doctor one time and asked him any advice for just going
into further school. And he said that he did that. Maybe not for situations, but just in general,
you know, whatever tidbit, whatever exam he had going on, he recorded on, I think, I mean, he's
the old man, he probably had like the actual recorders, you know, but he would say at any time
he was sitting somewhere, he just had a little headphone jack and he plug it up, you know,
he's eating lunch, he's listening to it. You know, maybe he's driving somewhere, he's listening to
it, he's waiting, he's listening to it. And he really spoke highly of it because he says,
he liked that it was his own voice. And he didn't know any research or anything. Maybe I didn't
ask, but he said the fact that you remember looking at information, you remember speaking it. And now
when you're listening to it, you're going through that in your mind again, you know, kind of like,
oh, this was happening when I was saying this. Yeah, I think like I anecdotally had the same
experience. Like I listened to like a fuck ton of podcasts, I call the time, like I spend, you know,
like every time I'm working out or had like time in between things, like in my car, like
hours and hours and hours of content. But it's so much like, I don't really absorb it all. But like
when I've taken the time to record something and like listen to it myself, like, one, I can't stand
the sign of my own voice, but two, I'm like, oh, like, this is me. And I took the time to make it
like it seems to, it seems to sink in a little more. So I think there is value in, in doing the
work to create that same thing with like making note cards, like you're studying for like, let's
say you're studying for your national registry, you can buy note cards pre-made like off of eBay
or off of Amazon or wherever you buy note cards, you say something. But if you take the time to
make them, like you probably get more value out of it, starting now. So I think there is value in
creating those things yourself versus just whatever else is out there. Plus you can like dial it into
like the specific things you need to know. Yes. Because anytime you have like, if you're listening
to a podcast, like maybe it's a really good podcast, but there's always like portions of it
that don't apply to what you want to know or to what your, what your clinical setting is.
So you kind of have to sift through it. Whereas if you're making something, it's like a hundred
percent relative. Yes. A hundred percent relevant. Not relative. That'd be weird. Yeah. I, I'm a huge
fan. I got this freaking binder. I've been working on this thing for quite some time. It's just in that
you remember medical school and you're kind of done learning things and you're just kind of doing
your clinical rotations. Like you're not done learning, but they're not forcing info down your
throat anymore. You know, I started making it then and it outgrew one binder, but I'm just a huge
thing. Even if it's, if it's typing, I'll have to go through it and highlight, you know, but I like
that. I just like the redundancy of it, you know, to where by time you're just purely reviewing it
without writing on it. Maybe it's your third or fourth or fifth time adding that information and
exactly what you were saying, how you can kind of tailor make your notes. Cause so many things out
there, like let's say you go online and you know, like the internet book of critical care, right?
Great website, very user friendly, but there's a lot of stuff on there. You know, it's a lot of stuff
to look at a lot of stuff. If you just want that one point, you know, so I really like to type it
up. If at all the time in the world, I just write it by hand because I rather enjoy doing things by
hand, but that's just not feasible. Our time is limited. Well, Brian, that's everything I got for
you this time.